welcome back to las vegas now one local
man has new york hustle
marine strength and vegas style he's
sharing his story of survival and
entrepreneurship
in his new inspiring book tenacity take
a look ron corey welcome to the show
hi thank you rocky i've heard so many
great things about you so i'm so excited
to finally share your story with our
viewers you are a
vegas businessman you survived cancer
and all of this to
continue achieving your dreams and now
you have a book called tenacity
so i'm really excited to tell people how
they can get the book and what's
what it's about it is my life story in
an autobiography
it's an inspirational motivational story
i think it helps people see
that a guy with nothing get it out
getting out of the marine corps in 1973
could come to a new town because i left
brooklyn new york when i enlisted
come to a new town with nothing i became
a casino dealer
a realtor and then after a couple years
purchased my first gaming tavern
and parlayed that one gaming tavern into
20 businesses
i like to think that maybe half the
population
have been touched by me in some way
with the variety of businesses whether
they bought a car
from my car one of my three car
dealerships in town
or been to one of my four gaming taverns
or used
presidential limousine service a company
i started in the 80s
or any one of a variety of other
businesses i want people to know it's a
true story
even though i've changed certain names
to
make it something that did not put off
or offend
while the content of the story is a
hundred percent accurate
we really found our fortunes in las
vegas
and the book does describe uh in in
opening certain businesses i encountered
some political
and police corruption the book describes
to
readers how i faced those challenges
and overcame them and how i prevailed in
each of the challenges
including some death threats i might uh
want people to know
uh vegas of old was certainly not the
town it is today
and i think my book tenacity uh is quite
entertaining
let's talk about the book specifically
because i see it behind you right
i see today american flag yep
the marine corps emblem the american
flag a little touch of the vegas welcome
to vegas symbol
with the brooklyn bridge which is part
of the subtitle of the book
uh former brooklyn i finds las vegas
fortune
going through the marine corps and it
touches on a lot of aspects of my life
the audiobook interestingly was done by
an actor named michael madsen
who people will know from reservoir dogs
in don nebraska
the website is ron coreyauthor.com or
they could go right to amazon
or barnes noble and enter tenacity by
ron corey
and they can order the book all right
thank you so much for your time ron this
was really cool
well thank you rocky i really enjoyed
doing this interview with you
great guy great story right there get
your copy of tenacity by ron corey on
amazon like you said and for more
information
just head to ron corey author we